こんにちはっす　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん“口癖”ってありますでしょうか
多分僕も無意識にあると思うんですけども
僕だったら例えば何か喋った時に
「ちょっと」って言葉がなんかつけがちなんですよ
なんで、すごい色んなことが
ちょっとになってしまう
そういう口癖があります
世の中にはぁ↑いろーんな人がいるので
色んな口癖があると思うんですけども
あのー、私の後輩のけんすけという男がおりましてですね、
その子の口癖がちょっとね、あのー…
ﾌｯｗ
ちょっと変なんですよ
どう変かと言いますと
あの、言葉…の、何かこう…
…”すごい”とか”強い”とか、なんか
”素敵”とか言いたい時に
必ずその…何か言いたいことの前に
をつけてしまう
どうなるかと言いますと
「いっっっちばんすごい」とか
「いっっっちばんかっこいい」とか
「これがいっっっちばんおいしい」とか
あらゆるものが1番
あらゆるものがナンバーワンになってしまう
で、彼が何か食べる度に
「いやいっっっちばんおいしい！」
で、その次カレー食べたら
「あ、いっっっちばんおいしい！」
…って彼の中の1位の変動が物凄いんですよ
どうなっているんだと
あいつはちょっと1位を甘く見すぎている
そんな何でもかんでも1番1番、全部1番つけてると
物事の差がつかなくて
彼はいつかパンクしてしまうと思うんですよ
彼にはもっと物事の本質の1番を見極めてもらいたいので
まあ、ちょっと
僕個人的な、簡単に1番1番って使ってほしくないんで
一回ちょっとこれヤラセじゃないんですけども
普通に何気なく日常を
後輩との日常を動画で撮るので
1時間ほど撮ってみて
何回彼が普通の生活の中で「１番〇〇」って言葉を使うのか
ちょっと見ていこうと思います
ではVTR、どうぞ
け)パンケーキ食べたい♪
は)パンｋ…パンケーキ？それ
け)ちゃんぽんってラーメンじゃない？もしかして
は)ちゃんぽんはラーメン。
け)ギリ
は)いや1番ラーメンよ
は)ふーん(？)
け)うんっ♪
は)1番美味い？
け)うん
け)1回モンストやります？
は)でもおにぎりやっぱね…最強やね
け)そう結局ご飯食べたかったから…
は)結局米よね
け)うん
は)うんめぇぇぇぇ
は)まじうめぇ
は)米が1番美味いな
は)だろうな…
は)だろうなぁ、けんすけ
け)もうお腹いっぱい
は)どんぐらい？
け)いきなり全員動くわけじゃなくって、誰か当たりに行かないとダメっすよ
は)ひどいなー
は)さては？
け)まあまあまあ、でも
け)勝てますよ、全然
は)けんすけベイブレードしようぜ
け)いいっすよ
は・け)スリィ、トゥー、ワンッ
ゴー　シューッ☆
は)はーっはっはっはっはっはっは！！！
け)嫌だもうーベイブレード、
け)勝てないっ…
け)待て、おまえ、ふざけんなよまじで
は)あーっはっは
け)もうー無理！
け)え！？これ強い！？もしかして
は)だって主人公のやつよ、今の
は)あれこれ待ってこれ…
け)待ってこれ回んない…(ボソッ)
け)え、すごい一個も外れてない
は)いやー、つ、強いんだよなー、多分
け)えっ
は・け)ゴー　シュート(控えめ)
け)やぁいい勝負いい勝負いい勝負！
け)いいよいいよいいよ！
け)おいっ
は)はははっ
は)木端微塵だ、けんすけ…
け)天才(？)
は)これさては…
は)さては…ｗ
け)待って待ってこれ一個混ぜた？
は)さては…？
け)さては？
は)まさかの…？
は)ｗｗｗ
は)やばいやばい！
け)やばいやばい待って
は)下から行け！
け)下から、下抉られてる！
け)やめてやめてやめて
は)あ"－－－！！！
は)あ"－－－！！！！！！
け)うぇぇぇぇい！！！
は)ｗｗｗ
け)あ"－－－！！！
は)あーすごいすごい！！
は)1番楽しいか…！！
は)これが俺の…！
は)えｑ☆ｗ×んｔ！！(聞き取り不可能)
け)いってってってってって(？)
け)待って本当にどうしようこれ(小声)
は)うまい！
は)こういうの待ってた☆
は)Tik Tok見ようぜTik Tok
け)いやこいつバカなの本当に
は）ｗｗｗ
け）パンケーキ食べたいって…
は）うわー！！！
は）可愛い本当に、俺の一押しアイドルの子
は）あとおっ〇いがくそでかい
け）ｗｗ
は）君と出会った奇跡が～♪　※スピッツ『空も飛べるはず』
け）はぁい↑
は・け）こ～の～胸に♪
は・け）うぇうぇうぇうぇうぇい♪
は）すごい！
け）え！
け）すごい！
け）え！PanteneのCMやん！もう
は）いやこれもうTSUBAKIでしょう、もう！
は）1番さらさらだなぁこれは！
け）え、すごい綺麗ー
け）触ってみたい...
は）ダメです。
は）結局糖分？
け）結局糖分。
は）はーい　というわけでけんすけさん、
け）えっ
は）今日の動画はですねぇ
け）うん
は）最近けんすけがー
は）何かある度にかなりの高確率で
は）「1番」ってつける…
け）「1番」つけるｗｗｗ
は）…っていう検証をやっておりましたぁ
は）動画回して約1時間で
は）物凄い数の”1番”を使っていて、
は）”ナンバーワン””が物凄い数生まれているわけです
け）いやナンバーワンが変動しているんですよね
は）いやでもけんすけ、唯一無二ってものがあってな
は）ナンバーワンはっ、けんすけ…ねっ…けんすｋ…
は）ナンバーワンはなっ
け）はっはっはっはっはｗｗｗ
は）ほらもう、もうー
は）1番よ、けんすけ
は）「1番うるさい」って言うけど多分1番うるさいのはまだあるよ。銅鑼とかジェット機とか
け）確かに確かに確かに
は）あ、”今日”なんだ
け）”今日”1番…
は）けんすけ、けんすｋ…けんすけ